my name is rubella Bosh and I'm a stage
director but I'm also an actor and
sometimes I'm a film director I do a lot
of work in the Opera so I'm pretty much
ever my finger and many many pies but my
main thing is I have a theatre company
called ex machina we're based in Quebec
City I thought that this morning would
be maybe interesting to explain to you
my method of working it's more fun to
tell stories as a group and it's more
fun and richer to take everybody's
experience and disciplines and make them
converge together you help the piece say
what it is that it wants to say so it's
not starting with that idea it's it's
letting it appear and imposing itself if
you look at the anthropology of theatre
it's about playing and that will bring
us to our resource today ex machina is
working on a new piece based on playing
cards the project is called playing
cards we believe that the content is is
in here you know that there's tons of
stories in this I believe that if we
give you that resource that you actually
can come up with your own interpretation
like I see cards and I have like - Rex
immediately
so it's a family thing it was a family
issue you know when I was talking about
the way we explore this and at least one
thing we could try this afternoon in the
playfulness of istic we try to play
cards just play cards just do that I
can't defend anything else
you can go down anytime I feel like it's
now hearts and the object is to get rid
of all your parts are there any cards
that special
okay all games are over alright so the
last thing I want to set take some time
to to do which is something I always try
to do as part of the exploration thing
that well just do like one big
collective drawing there's no rules to
this you just draw the impressions that
you have what we did together today
about cards whatever
I'm just gonna quickly go around
everybody just to know what who
contributed what I added the axe to the
players to the main cable Oh they'd this
axe here that's the X okay I did the
outline of this purple figure the Train
that peel turn into a train yeah what's
that oh um so it's as you go left to
right it's the number of cards that you
need for the hand and poker so it's one
card one pair two pair three of a kind
that's an interesting pattern I added a
mustache with experience we've learned
that we should not force connections we
let them and eventually to three things
seems to go together and go oh there's a
pattern there and then we sit and we
score which is of course is a weird way
of thinking because we're used but we
brought up to say you're the master
you're the writer you're the guy who who
controls the show who says to show what
to do we say no it's exactly the
opposite we trust that the show will
tell us what to do it's it's an obscure
process I agree
any questions any any doubts and fears
haha
so good luck with everything and have
fun that's the most important thing have
fun and be playful
you